hello everybody and welcome to my first
investment video now uh what we're going
to be investing in today is going to be
a rare item it's not going to be a cheap
item with a margin I think is going to
raise up in the next couple weeks or
months or whatever uh it's going to be a
rare item that has completely dropped in
price due to raids coming out just
recently and that item is going to be
the third age Mage hat now I'm just
quickly looking through some items on G
tracker um a link will be in the
description for the website here
and uh you can see just as raids came
out the price completely plummeted down
to an all-time low of about 20 mil now
if we look back at the last year the
lowest it was ever at before was 31 mil
back in August and it didn't stay there
very long it rose right back up again to
40 mil plus uh if we go down to the day
the most recent data looks like we could
probably snag one for about 23 mil and
it does look like it's on the rise back
up uh so bam came down plummeted and
looks like it's rising back up and uh
what makes me feel like this is a pretty
safe investment is the interesting thing
is if we go uh into the month and when
the raids came out uh more were traded
now that makes sense but the amount in
the game is kind of finite it's not like
people can go and get these upon command
they come into the game very slowly from
clue Scrolls it's not like people went
and just killed a bunch of monsters or
did a bunch of quests or whatever to get
the item
uh there's they're only obtainable via
clue scroll so my rationale is that
because there's similar amount of them
to the game that their value will retain
similar to what it was before raids came
out and the price should return maybe
not exactly the 39 mil or whatever was
that but I think it should definitely go
back up uh I might not be completely
right about that but I think it's a safe
investment so we're going to go ahead
and buy one of these uh now we have 20
mil on our account so we'll see if we
can buy it for pretty much what
this cost is so
third age Mage hat just double check
that is the correct
item and uh if we go down to the day we
just want to make sure we buy it for one
before it raises up hopefully so we'll
just pop it in there for 20 how much
money do we actually have
here H let's just let's just buy it for
that 23
95k and see if we in to buy it yes we
did we bought it for 23
mil and uh today the date is the January
the January 11th so we are going to
leave it in here for a while uh we're
going to try not to pay attention to it
cuz that's how I end up dumping the item
a lot so I it took about let's see a
week for the price to drop down here
it's not going to recover that quickly I
wouldn't imagine but we'll leave it in
here at least for the length of the bond
that we bought which is about two weeks
and we'll check back with you guys then
all right wish me
luck all right guys we're back and it's
been about 2 days since the last clip
here now if we have a look at our third
age Mage hat here it has risen up by
about 5 mil which is pretty good pretty
happy with a 5 mil flip but I'm not sure
if I'm going to sell it or not cuz it's
still below its alltime low over the
last year and uh it still kind of looks
like the item might be rising up it's
kind of leveled off the last uh day and
a half or so but we bought in about here
and it's up to 28 mil looks like it
still might be going up so I think we're
going to hold on to that item for longer
um but thanks to a uh bit of an
intervention by the G tracker staff I do
have a little bit more cash to work with
so big shout out to them um they Supply
me with pretty much 33 mil to help
rebuild my account and uh so we're going
to add another third age item to our
flipping queue for now uh so that I've
got an extra 19 mil so far on this
account and of course the third age Mage
hat it's going to bring our total cash
here to
about close to 50 mil so now I've been
looking at a bunch of the different
third age pieces of equipment and of the
four that we can afford I kind of want
to do one that I might be able to
actively flip a little more instead of
just leaving it in for a day hoping it
completes so either that'll have have to
be the third age amulet or the third age
ranging legs seem to have the most uh
volume traded still not extremely high
by any means but let's see the uh third
age
amulet um and the third age ranging legs
uh the third age amulet has been trading
a lot more recently because of raids uh
but generally still had 15 20 upwards of
30 pretty much a day uh the ranging legs
a little more consistent 15 20 a day uh
so I'm kind of leaning towards the
ranging legs just CU I feel like they
might actually trade more frequently
we'll go with the uh ranging legs so
maybe we an offer in for a bit lower uh
maybe 15.6 mil or so yeah so third age
range in
legs and we'll put it in for 15
point six mil how about 15 601k
we'll probably sell this if it gets
above 30 mil but who knows like I mean
it's still quite low compared to its
historical values all right we'll update
you in a little while all right we're
back and we did manage to sell our third
a range legs for a 500K profit which is
pretty decent only took probably 3 or 4
hours to flip uh so pretty happy with
that and uh we do have our third age M
hat still I'm thinking we're going to
pop it into sell for maybe 28 or 29 mil
I'd be extremely happy with a 5 or 6 mil
profit and the item has leveled off a
lot um but first I think we'll put
another offer in for these third age
ranging legs still a pretty decent
margin 3 400 500k and uh they do come in
decently quickly probably within an hour
I'd actually buy it assuming they have
the right price and all all right so
we'll put an offer in for roughly uh
16.4 mil and leave that in for a while
16 401k and uh just buy the one and I
think we're going to pop this into cell
cuz if I remember correctly the Mage hat
has actually evened off a little bit and
doesn't seem to be rising up I know I
said I'd leave it in for a while uh but
at the same time I would like to have
that money to actively flip some more 30
AG items as opposed to just sitting on
this one for I don't know a month or so
also my bond will expire and under a
week and a half or something and you can
see it kind of has leveled off so we'll
probably dump it maybe for 28 point 9
mil or something around there hopefully
we can sell it while we're at work and
we'll do 28 875 and we'll come back with
some more progress all right so we have
another third age range leg flip coming
in this one for a little bit more it's
going to be about
580k uh which I'm pretty happy about
again pretty easy to flip as you can see
we did two in a row for over a m in
profit so we'll definitely go ahead and
put another offer in for the range legs
I don't think they're raising up anymore
uh but we'll still probably still try to
flip them even if they are declining all
right so we've gone and rechecked it on
GE tracker so it looks like we could
even buy it for a bit cheaper maybe 16.3
mil and it looks like it's selling for a
700k profit which would be pretty
awesome uh so we put it in for 16 301k
and come back when we flipped it so we
did actually sell our third age Mage hat
now unfortunately it did drop down we
probably lost one or 2 mil in profit
that being said we still got 3.6 mil off
that which you can't really be upset
about really in the end of the day
uh we probably could have gotten more
but it was dropping down now it's down
to only a 1 and a half mil profit so who
knows um but we sold that 3.6 mil profit
there the third age range legs got us
another
550k in profit uh so 4.1 mil right there
uh just just as easy as that guys so
we'll probably go have a look maybe at
the 3 age kite Shield this time uh we
can only buy one of them at a time but
looks like the margin might be 8 900k uh
since the third age Mage hat uh has not
actually a good margin on it really
right now it's just the fact that it
raised up that allowed us to get such a
decent profit from it uh but for third
age kite Shield maybe put an offer in
for somewhere around 43 mil uh
600 and uh yeah again we're going to
work this is kind of how we're doing it
we're leaving the offers in for a while
they do do take a while to complete uh
but it is worth it so we'll be back in a
bit all right we're back with another
flip the third age kite Shield did flip
again for about 800k in profit uh which
is pretty awesome this actually bought
and sold very quickly uh probably only
an hour and a half or so and uh yeah
that's another almost another Mill in
profit pretty
consistently um good flips for all the
third age equipment right now cuz most
of it has dropped down to an all-time
low so it's a lot less risky cuz it's
not likely to drop anymore um but yeah
we can see here we'll probably go try
and buy another piece of the third age
um I guess the third age kite Shield
again while the margin isn't great right
now it has been good in the past and uh
we're just about to head off to another
8 hour shift so hopefully we can buy it
when we're at work um probably for more
than that uh we'll do 43 and
400k and uh yeah we'll be back in a
little bit and hopefully with another
800k in profit all right guys so the
kite Shield didn't end up buying so we
decide to switch to two items instead uh
the Mage hat and the third age amulet
which is still buying the Mage hat
doesn't actually have a very good margin
on it right now but we're doing it
anyway because we couldn't really find
another item uh so we bought it for
about 25.1 mil so hopefully sell it for
a 300K profit so it's not nearly
comparable to the rest of them but it's
something and uh we'll come back when it
is sold all right guys so we sold the
Mage hat for a whopping 30 game profit I
know it's not much but uh whatever we
just want the item sold and I think
that's where we're going to just just
end the video for now I hope you guys
are enjoying these kind of uh less
series oriented videos obviously I'm
still going to have my series uh but I
could just kind of like doing uh just
flips no structure just seeing what I
can get for the items maybe a bit of a
theme like today we're just doing some
third age items uh but just no
restrictions nothing just just being
able to flip which is kind of nice uh
today we made a 6 milon profit we have
it all kind of logged here I'll just
bring the notepad in for a second each
flip log cuz I know I did get some more
money there wasn't a concurrent kind of
starting amount uh but still pretty
happy with that progress that 6 mil
going into the bank another 6 mil to
recover from my hack uh so if you guys
like these types of videos please leave
it a like rating so I know uh what kind
of content you guys want to see and uh
I'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
n